merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre collègue
222 jours de trop
222 jours de trop au terme duquel nous
mesurons provisoirement le désastre le
jeudi 24 février 2022 à 5h30 du matin
sur ordre du gouvernement de Vladimir
Poutine la Russie envahissait l'Ukraine
faisant basculer l'histoire de notre
vieux continent depuis ce jour les
horreurs de la guerre ne cessent de
retentir jusqu'à nous de la ville de
Bucha théâtre d'un massacre où il y a
quelques mois encore des familles avec
leurs enfants enjambés des corps de
civils gisant sur le sol aux
bombardement d'un hôpital et d'une
maternité à Mario Paul en passant par
rizium ville devenue un immense
cimetière dans lequel plusieurs
centaines de sépultures de civils ont
été découvertes quand les vivants
survivent à l'heure où nous parlons sans
eau sans gaz sans électricité
depuis plus de six mois les dépêches
successives nous parviennent rendent
compte de l'état des combats en même
temps qu'elle trace une géographie
funeste alors que l'humanité a donné à
voir la plus cruelle version d'elle-même
nous formons ce vœu que ces crimes de
guerre soient jugés et punies la semaine
dernière
Vladimir Poutine faisait le choix de
l'escalade précipitant un peu plus
l'humanité au seuil d'une guerre totale
pour justifier l'annexion des
territoires du don-basse son
gouvernement a organisé des référendums
illégaux Vladimir Poutine a déclaré la
mobilisation partielle de sa population
il a brandit la menace nucléaire pour
couvrir sa guerre d'agression nous le
disons avec force ces décisions sont des
provocations inacceptables la communauté
internationale doit faire bloc pour
refuser le chantage nucléaire et
s'abstenir de faciliter l'engrenage
lorsque l'on fait primer la force brute
et la terreur nucléaire ni la paix ni la
sécurité internationale ne garantie pour
les puissances nucléaires seule la
négociation peut permettre de sortir de
l'impasse de la guerre totale celle-ci a
d'autant plus de chances d'aboutir si le
peuple russe refuse son enroulement dans
une guerre illégale notre groupe
parlementaire la France insoumise
nupaise salut la résistance de celles et
ceux qui avec courage manifeste contre
la décision de guerre de leur pays
les foyers de contestation qui se
forment en Russie doivent nous rappeler
une chose nous ne confondons pas le
peuple russe avec le gouvernement de
Vladimir Poutine le rôle de la France
dans cette crise et devrait aux côtés de
l'Ukraine pour le respect bikewide du
droit international la protection des
civils et le retour de la paix dans cet
objectif la poursuite du dialogue avec
la Russie était nécessaire le rôle de la
France est également d'alerter pour
éviter qu'une tragédie ne s'ajoute à la
souffrance le 4 mars dernier des Tyrus
frappaient la centrale nucléaire de
zaporiggia nous alertons depuis des mois
sur le risque les centrales nucléaires
deviennent des cibles de cette guerre et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon appelait dès mars
2022 à l'envoi de casque bleu pour
sécuriser les centrales ukrainiennes
la catastrophe dans la catastrophe c'est
également la prise pour cible des
conditions même d'habitude du territoire
ukrainien les attaques contre des dépôts
pétroliers le désastre industriel de
louange qu'en avril ou 4 tonnes d'acides
nitrique ont été déversées la
contamination de l'eau et des sols
mettent en péril la santé humaine des
Ukrainiens sur plusieurs générations la
guerre produit aussi un effet d'aubaine
pour des oligares qui se positionnent
sur de grands projets industriels nous
joignons notre voie à celle de la
résistance ukrainienne qui refuse que la
guerre soit un prétexte à la prédation
sur leurs ressources naturelles pour
finir notre groupe encourage à ce que
tous les moyens de la diplomatie soient
mis en oeuvre afin d'éviter l'escalade
le seul chemin rationnel est celui de la
paix madame la Première ministre je le
réaffirme ici pour mon groupe la France
sonnerait à organiser à accueillir une
conférence pour la sécurité et la
négociation d'un plan de paix et de
garantie mutuelle
telles sont les pistes prioritaires que
nous identifions mais puisque ce débat
porte également sur les conséquences de
la guerre en Ukraine sur la France il
nous faut alors redoubler de rigueur qui
compte affirmerait que la guerre en
Ukraine serait l'unique source de la
situation économique que nous
connaissons dans le pays s'exposerait au
mensonges au commencement la pandémie de
covid-19 disloquer les chaînes
d'interdépendance et des organisé les
chaînes de production mondialisées la
distorsion du marché entraînait une
folie spéculative et l'explosion des
prix la guerre en Ukraine a fait
cachever ce chaos pour prendre seulement
l'exemple de la crise énergétique
celle-ci a pour origine un choc gazier
d'abord européen puis un choc
d'électricité lié à l'organisation de
notre marché européen les sanctions
contre la Russie ont même aggravé la
hausse des prix des hydrocarbures et
permis à la Russie de voir ses bénéfices
commerciaux exploser cette année dans ce
contexte
comment ne pas s'interroger sur leur
pertinence quelle est l'efficacité des
sanctions quand elles échappent à leur
cible et se retournent contre nous notre
cible et le régime de l'oligarchie russe
cette certitude doit nous servir de
principe d'action pour frapper le
système en son cœur madame la première
minute en toute circonstances et ne vous
en déplaise la faillite du marché de
l'énergie avec commencé avant la guerre
en Ukraine ces conséquences sont vécues
de plein fouet par les Français en un an
les prix du gros de l'électricité sur le
marché européen ont été multipliés par
10 et les prix du gaz par vin
concrètement les factures des Françaises
et Français augmenteront en moyenne de
200 à 300 euros par an alors lorsque
Emmanuel Macron évoque la fin de
l'abondance au sujet des bouleversements
énergétiques comment ne pas voir
l'impréparation flagrante dont votre
gouvernement a été coupable
cela fait plusieurs mois que RTE vous
alerte dans le vide sur la sécurité de
notre approvisionnement en énergie notre
dépendance à un parc nucléaire
vieillissant et à l'importation
d'énergie fossile ne date pas dire son
exposition a des problèmes de corrosion
est connu depuis janvier 2022 des avril
2022 des pays européens ont pris des
mesures l'Italie limite la température
dans les bâtiments publics interdit les
publicités lumineuses et réduit
l'éclairage nocturne l'Allemagne conçoit
un plan de sobriété et annonce la
nationalisation de son premier
producteur gazier tandis qu'en France
c'est seulement en juillet 2022 que le
mot sobriété affleure à la bouche du
président de la République madame la
Première ministre la situation
internationale ne serait destinée
d'elle-même un modèle d'action à suivre
ce que vous faites à chaque étape de la
période de chaos et de pénurie que nous
connaissons ce sont des choix politiques
la guerre en Ukraine ne peut servir
d'arguments commode pour dissimuler les
dysfonctionnements du marché et votre
allégeance la logique néolibérale qui la
guide baissez l'indemnisation des
chômeurs raboter les retraites refuser
d'augmenter les impôts sur les plus
riches fermez une d'oublier la
définition d'un super profit refusé de
taxer les profiteurs de crise d'une part
lancer un concours Lépine de la tenue
vestimentaire d'autres parts ce sont des
choix politiques ce sont les vôtres
ne nous faites pas croire qu'il n'était
pas possible de faire autrement faire
payer au précaire de ce pays votre
désinvolture à l'égard des poches les
plus remplies ne relève pas de la
nécessité notre groupe parlementaire n'a
cessé de plaider pour une taxe sur les
profiteurs de crise cette proposition
est désormais portée par un alliage
étonnant de représentants puisqu’après
la Commission européenne le rapporteur
de l'ONU le FMI c'est désormais le chef
économiste de la Banque centrale
européenne qu'ils ont qui joint sa voie
à la nôtre mais vous la refusez non vous
lui préférez votre générateur de demande
monsieur Bruno Le Maire qui enjoint
poliment les multinationales à
contribuer à hauteur de leurs moyens
vous applaudissez dès demain les miettes
distribuées par les uns et les autres
tandis que les PME et les TPE sont
étranglés par la hausse des prix et
contrainte de réduire leur production
votre isolement sur le sujet n'a d'égal
qu'un attachement absurde au mécanisme
de spéculation du marché les plus
insensés total énergie après avoir
dégagé un bénéfice net record de 16
milliards de dollars l'année dernière
s'apprête à distribuer un acompte sur
dividendes exceptionnels de 2,62
milliards d'euros à ses actionnaires
sont seuls mérite sur la période et de
tirer injustement profit d'une rente de
situations là encore vous aviez la
possibilité de tabler sur ce type de
marge juteuse pour bloquer les prix à la
baisse mais vous ne l'avez pas fait les
français payent leur café 15% plus cher
leur pote 29% plus cher leur huile 137%
plus cher mais vous vous retranchez
derrière l'inflation pour refuser
d'augmenter les salaires pourtant vous
savez que nous ne faisons pas face à une
boucle salaire prix mais une boucle
pénurie profit vous avez au moins le
mérite de la clarté ce sont les plus
pauvres qui paieront l'inflation et
c'est eux comme les 12 millions de
personnes en précarité énergétique que
Vous exhortez à faire des petits
pourquoi la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale a proposé un
référendum d'initiative partagée visant
à taxer les super profits en croire
votre entêtement irresponsable seul le
recours à la démocratie serait de nature
à vous faire réviser vos priorités c'est
aussi pourquoi nous organons le 16
octobre prochain une marche contre la
vie chère l'inaction climatique et
contre la réforme des retraites marche à
laquelle nous invitons le plus grand
nombre à se rendre
j'achève sur ces mots
vous nous ne ferez jamais croire que vos
choix politiques sont le produit d'une
nécessité qui s'imposerait à vous la
guerre en Ukraine ne peut servir
d'arguments pour mener une guerre
sociale aux Français compter sur nous
pour montrer à chaque étape qu'une
alternative est possible
[Applaudissements]
merci